ILLEGAL.
THEY WILL PLAN RACIAL ISSUES,
MARK MY WORDS.
RUNNING IS NOW SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN.
HE WILL BE PRESIDING OVER ALL OF
THIS, SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
IT’S INTERESTING HOW THE
PRESIDENT WAS BROKEN BY THEM,
RIGHT?
NOW THEY ARE THREATENING --
>> IT’S PRETTY OBVIOUS THEY WANT
AN OUTCOME.
THEY WILL DESTROY ANYBODY’S LIFE
TO KEEP THE SEATS OPEN.
THEY TRIED TO DESTROY
BRETT KAVANAUGH SO THEY CAN FILL
THE SEAT.
THEY WERE DUMB ENOUGH TO SAY
THAT.
I’VE SEEN THIS MOVIE BEFORE.
IT’S NOT GOING TO WORK.
IT DIDN’T WORK WITH KAVANAUGH.
WE GOT THE VOTES TO CONFIRM
JUSTICE GINSBURG’S REPLACEMENT
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THE COMMITTEE.
WERE GOING TO REPORT THE
NOMINATION OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
TO THE FLOOR OF THE
UNITED STATES SENATE SO WE CAN
VOTE BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THAT’S THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROCESS.
AFTER KAVANAUGH, EVERYTHING
CHANGED WITH ME.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO INTIMIDATE
ME, MITCH McCONNELL, ANYBODY
ELSE.
I’M GETTING OUT SPENT 4-1.
IF YOU WANT TO HELP ME FIGHT
BACK, GO TO LINDSAY GRAHAM.COM.
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE A PROCESS
THAT YOU’LL BE PROUD OF.
THE NOMINEE WILL BE SUPPORTED BY
EVERY REPUBLICAN IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND WE HAVE
THE VOTES TO CONFIRM THE JUDGE,
THE JUSTICE ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THAT’S WHAT’S COMING.
>> Sean: SENATOR, THEY WANT TO
STACK THE COURT.
THEY WANT TO END THE FILIBUSTER
FOR LEGISLATION.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT,
IMPEACHING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
ALL THE PRECEDENT HAVE BEEN
BROKEN SO FAR BY DEMOCRATS.
ANOTHER GOING TO TAKE IT TO THIS
LEVEL.
DO YOU -- THEY HAVE ALREADY DONE
IT BEFORE.
WHY WOULD WE NOT BELIEVE HIM
NOW?
>> NAME ONE LIBERAL JUSTICE
NOMINATED BY A DEMOCRAT THAT HAD
THEIR LIFE RUINED.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT CHANGING
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
IF THEY KEEP THE HOUSE, THE
SENATE AND THE WHITE HOUSE, THIS
COUNTRY WILL CHANGE
FUNDAMENTALLY.
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE WILL BE
OBLITERATED.
WE WILL GO TO POPULAR VOTE.
D.C. AND PUERTO RICO WILL BECOME
STATES.
THERE WILL BE 104 SENATORS.
IT GOES ON AND ON AND ON.
THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF THE SUPREME COURT.
THEY WILL ALL BE LIBERAL.
THEY’RE GOING TO TAKE THE
PROCESS, THE RULES, AND CHANGE
THEM TO THEIR BENEFIT.
THE ONLY THING STOPPING THEM IS
YOU, THE VOTER.
IF YOU WANT TO HELP ME AND OTHER
REPUBLICANS, GET IN THE GAME.
THEY ARE KILLING US FINANCIALLY.
I AM IN SOUTH CAROLINA, NOT
EXACTLY LIBERAL STATE MY
OPPONENT IS GOING TO RAISE
$80 MILLION.
I NEED CONSERVATIVES TO HELP ME.
YOU NEED TO HELP US ALL.
LINDSEY GRAHAM.COM.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY,
BARBRA STREISAND, ROSIE
O’DONNELL, THEY WANT TO TELL